a large-scale attack by Russian
barbarians on the capital and regional centers of
Ukraine in Kyiv, we can see the morning luchanka of
which district, in particular, in the center of our
city. Also, the aggressor hit several
objects of critical infrastructure,
according to data at this time
, five people were killed by rocket attacks in our city
51 victims are
now 42 42 people are in the
city's institutions, medical facilities, all city
services are working under the state of
emergency, they are reacting badly, overcoming the
consequences of the attack. Now we see
the communal services are working, the threat continues,
and therefore I ask everyone to ignore security and
air warning signals during the
alarm, please stay in Ukraine
Take  Please, diesel locomotive, water,
food supply, charger for phones and in the
city, please, no guests needed. No,
please, do not stop by. I remind you that the
metro station is working as a shelter at the moment
after the alarm was turned off, which lasted for five and a
half hours.
we work we do  for everything to ensure the
provision of the city. Thank you to all the workers for their
understanding and endurance of the
enemy. Here we have nothing to scare him, we
keep calm and he is
balanced together